[Musique]
culture première jean paul ney laddh
musique ciné au programme de ce culture
première du jeudi 26 avril voici mes
invités de leur s boyer qui n'est pas
encore arrivé
ça rime bien accompagné par rick le bo
de tricot de peau à venir un cd avec le
groupe en accompagnement c'est en mai
ils sont là tous les deux n'ont pas
encore et sera ensuite je pense pour
nous parler de cette aventure commencée
il ya bientôt trois ans un festival à
expobat saint-paul les 11 12 et 13 mai
prochains
celui des îles de l'océan indien au
rendez-vous les seychelles maurice et la
réunion avec quinze artistes au total
thierry villendeuil pour nous en parler
enfin cinéma ya 20 ans l'opération
pilotée par la lanterne magique fait son
cinéma du 4 au 6 mai au la case et au
cristal à saint-benoît c'est dû signer
pour les tout petits dès 3 ans
la mise en on est assuré par kahlo ce
soir l'illustration musicale est signée
tricot de peau et des artistes de
l'océan indien
culture première galerie ouvrant une
autre émission l approche des vacances
scolaires vous nous donner une idée de
voyage et un roman à emporter dans votre
valise c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
bonsoir chers auditeurs c'est vrai que
ça fait longtemps que j'avais envie de
vous parler d'un pays et ce pays c'est
la namibie waouh
voilà ce que je me suis dit quand j'y
suis allé pour la première fois au mois
de janvier pour le présenter un peu ce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas la namibie
cela un pays situé au sud-ouest de
l'afrique c'est beaucoup plus grand que
la france 300 fois plus grand que la
réunion c'est l'un des pays les plus
secs et les moins peuplés du monde et
comment vous avez découvert et bien
grâce à un livre cartographie de l'oubli
c'est un roman écrit par un auteur
français niche labuzan qui étaient en
lice pour le prix du roman métis l'année
dernière et donc jean paul c'est à cette
occasion que je les lui cartographie
l'oubli en fait c'est un lit qui raconte
l'arrivée des soldats allemands en
namibie à la fin du 19e siècle pour
coloniser le pays
mais très vite les allemandes ont
massacré les peuples indigènes les
hereros cv d'un match pour s'approprier
leurs terres et donc labuzan décrivent
cette colonisation sanglante dans son
roman
c'est un roman très très bien écrit en
plus sur un sujet inédit donc le
génocide edr et rose et sur un pays pas
si connu que ça en fait à la namibie
jean paul vous savez on dit que tout
livre est en voyage et bien ce livre là
en plus d'en être en éveil votre
curiosité et vous donne envie de faire
une traversée de la namibie
c'est un livre magique un peu comme la
lanterne magique c'est un hobby c'est
comment alors son jeu de mots que ce
qu'on y voit
et vient à la namibie pour moi c'est le
pays de l'immensité du grandiose on voit
des désert à perte de vue
on va d'immenses plaines avec quelques
arbres comme ça tombait nulle part comme
le raconte cartographie on voit aussi de
gigantesques dunes de sable rouge des
lieux quasi lunaire avec dérange et tout
d'un coup un troupeau de springbok qui
passe ou visite des parcs comme le parc
d'etosha aussi c'est parfait pour faire
des safaris et pour voir mais des
centaines et des centaines d'animaux
comme des girafes des zèbres des
éléphants en fait la namibie pour poissy
ce qui m'a le plus marqué c'est entendre
en lion lui rugir à 2 heures du matin là
à 500 mètres de vous
alors mosson wind hook la capitale le
wind pape et de deux jours ainsi une
ville pas cher en fait la namibie n'est
pas chère du tout en fait c'est une
ville très paisible aussi et je vous
conseille d'y voir notamment un musée le
national mieux via maintenait mais bien
qu'ils racontent
justement le génocidaire et rose dont
parle encore cartographie comment on
voit jusqu'en nommé mi longs des
personnages de cartographie fait un pari
vindu quand 11h pour nous depuis la
réunion c'est beaucoup plus rapide
on prend un avion pour johannesburg et
de là on en prend un second pour windows
6 heures de vol au total et sur place
vous louez une voiture pour faire une
traversée nord-sud sans aucune
difficulté
il n'y a pas de problème d'insécurité là
bas c'est idéal pour une première
découverte de l'afrique noire
la poétesse capable d'oublier nom
revient à la réunion atterrissage à
saint-denis à la fabrique est exact et
là je m'adresse à tous les jeunes qui
sont passionnés de théâtre qui ont déjà
le bac ou sont en passe de l'obtenir et
qui ont moins de 24 ans quand la science
pour vous jean-paul n'ont fait que moi
si vous réussissez vous suivrez à
limoges de septembre 2018 à juin 2010 9
une classe préparatoire qui va vous
préparer au métier donc deux comédiens
et aux concours d'entrée dans les écoles
supérieures d'art dramatique de
métropole pourquoi ce concours bah en
fait tout est parti d'un triste constat
on s'est rendu compte qu'il ya très peu
de comédiens des drones dans 9 langues
autres moeurs voilà dans les écoles
supérieures d'art dramatique et sur les
planches métropolitaine du coup on a
décidé de créer cette formation pour les
aider à réussir leur admission dans ces
écoles puis pour les rendre plus
visibles sur les planches et cette
formation va comprendre des ateliers
d'interprétation d'écriture de travail
corporel ainsi que des rencontres
d'artistes et finalement l'examen donc
sera est à passer entre au mois de mai
il y aura trois épreuves orales qui pour
juger les aptitudes artistiques et la
motivation du candidat
donc je dis à tous les jeunes qui sont
intéressés inscrivez vous allez passer
cet entretien et si vous avez besoin
d'informations supplémentaires
l'équipe du théâtre du grand marché à
saint denis est là pour répondre à
toutes vos questions
[Musique]
culture première bonsoir vous connaissez
certainement tricot de peau et un
certain règle le beau mais s'ils
n'avaient pas lui qui sera question
entièrement aujourd'hui mais de dos le
reste de l'europe est une jeune
parisienne née de parents réunionnais
elle est venue dans l'île il ya bientôt
trois ans mais juste avant il ya eu la
rencontre avec tricot bonsoir à tous les
deux vous avez failli rater votre relevé
parce que encore un peu on commençait
sans vous jean paul et des très bonne
humeur comme vous l'avez constaté alors
de le reste voyez donc c'est vous qui
êtes allés à la rencontre de pau où
c'est le contraire eh ben c'est un peu
les deux en fait
en vérité j'ai d'abord j'ai rencontré
marine marines à rien voilà sur un
spectacle de théâtre parce qu'à la base
je suis comédienne et donc du coup j'ai
joué dans un spectacle qui s'appelle
chéri concentre toi s'il vous plaît et
donc marine avait fait là la composition
musicale
voilà du spectacle et c'est comme ça que
j'ai rencontré tricot de peau donc du
coup j'ai écouté très coup de pot et on
s'est rapprochés comme ça et ça a
commencé comme ça on fait après il ya eu
j'ai eu envie de chanter voilà et donc
du coup on est partis là-dessus et on a
eu envie ensuite de créer un personnage
et de raconter des histoires alors j'ai
pas vraiment entendu son puisqu'un le
disque puisque il n'est pas encore sorti
on entendra tout à l'heure j'ai sur le
net ce que j'ai pu entendre un morceau
c'est un univers très particulier 1-2 le
reste voyez vous avez des univers
complètement différent là tous les deux
et vous rêvez avoir être en
compatibilité
bah oui je crois que ça existe au sein
de tout le monde en a on a plusieurs
facettes de notre propre personne et on
avait envie de justement de dénoter de
sortir de tricot de peau
papaux quitté a définitivement tricot de
peau c'est particulier c'est de faire
faute pour des rumeurs oui voilà reprise
on peut faire plein de trucs et l'idée
c'était vraiment d'essayer de faire une
proposition en chansons réunionnaise
mais dans un
l'hiver est dans une ambiance qui est un
peu particulier rendu résident attendu
pour relier que ça voilà que la
mayonnaise va prendre de leur s boyer
bain pour qui le public évidemment je
pense que vous vous adressez au peuple
ukrainien oui balbin pour le moment ça
s'essayer une bonne un bon accueil voilà
merci
il ya un très bon accueil en fait pour
l'instant c'est ce qui nous encourage à
continuer en fait alors que vous êtes
bon accueil de la part de qui du public
vous êtes déjà présenté japon oui en
fait ben oui oui au départ j'avais fait
les premières parties du spectacle
tricot de peau skopies donc on avait que
cinq chansons à ce moment là mais je
parle de l'aude qui sape la commande et
le titre est un titre s'éloigner de leur
essai éponyme de leur est d'accord de le
reste à vous avez déjà chanté sur scène
oui oui d'accord au coeur quand je la
laisse continuer oui avant de se lancer
dans l'album on n'a rien on a essayé nos
chansons sur scène c'est comme ça qu'on
a décidé de faire l'album en fait c'est
parce que justement on a voilà on a vu
qu'il y avait un bon accueil du public
et du coup on a eu envie d'aller plus
loin
combien de chansons 13 tout ça en douce
rose sur l'album sont présentes 11 juin
- 11 chansons mais on a encore
their way n'a pas tout mis sur l'album
c'est un choix on avait envie d'en
garder pour un peu plus tard créer des
événements voilà
et vous avez pris qui a composé ses vous
fait le reste les tout le monde en sort
on sait l'équipe
comment ça s'est passé disons que je
suis à la composition
en règle générale parfois on collabore
sur ces pour trouver certaines mélodies
pour essayer d'être au plus proche des
capacités vocales de
ne leur reste donc et voilà mais
globalement c'est moi qu'à fabriquer
puis après j'ai lu j'ai regardé une
vidéo qui vous était consacré donc sur
une site vous disais vous bébé baigner
là en france dans une atmosphère créole
le parent par deux fois dans l'histoire
de dolores les parents parler créole oui
alors je dis dans l'histoire des
douloureuses parce qu'en fait il s'agit
d'un album concept en fait d'accord en
couple vous parlez donc de l'album moi
je parle de votre vie
je me déconnecte de l'album dans votre
vie à vous quand vous étiez en france 2
n'était plus jeunes vos parents par des
créoles
non mais regardez pas irriter pour
mémoire pouvait vivre austruy quand même
oui oui oui mes parents parler créole et
vous parle du chrono série d'accords
donc ça se fait c'est ce qui explique
que vous n'aviez n'ayez pas trop
d'accent oreilles lorsque vous chantez
géante entre hommes et femmes
oui bah oui non non j'ai pas d'accent
oreilles l'accent pointu on va dire
l'accent pointu qu'elle a connu en
français voilà bon bien alors cet album
il a une particularité c'est que il sera
pas en vente pour demander aux europe
league donc de faire ce qu'on appelle de
financement participatif c'est ça fait
sur kiss kiss bang bang et pourquoi
balle passée le faisait passer dessous
bah oui tout à fait tricot de peau ça
donne de l'argent quand même bah disons
que ça joue
les artistes ont payé quand il joue on
fait le maximum pour ça après
bah il suffit de poser la question aux
financeurs allait demander à monsieur
didier à l'adac tout ça il y en a qui se
passe de saison tout à fait ouais bien
sûr ils sont très forts et puis mais ils
sont très commerciaux s'ils sont peu
nombreux
ah oui mais y'en à rihanna avoue si
quand même la réunion ya pas mal de deux
groupes qui fonctionne qui se
débrouillent les producteurs qui
fabriquent leur musique est qu'ils
arrivent à la vendre et très bien j'ai
l'impression en tout cas enfin c'est je
les connais pas mais il me semble en
tout cas vous trouvez que nous reste que
c'est un monde entre les cas la réunion
je vous propose la france métropolitaine
parce que ça grenouille d'artistes c'est
difficile ici
ben oui c'est difficile même moi même je
suis pas intermittents du spectacle je
travaille à côté du coup oui bien sûr
c'est difficile je présenterai volonté à
vos côtés il vient d'avoir un nouveau
site va faire votre promo puisque c'est
cet emprunt c'est voilà ça c'est un site
tout neuf qui parle de culture bien
alors vous en êtes vous dans votre
recherche d'argent on est à presque 70 %
de la somme demandée et il nous reste
une vingtaine de jours bon allez on va
parler dessous il vous faut combien et
combien vous savez je récoltais var on
doit être à 2700 et des bananes et il
nous faut quatre mille pas plus que ça
oh ben on va pas exagérer non plus non
seulement on donne des sous pour
finaliser notre album on prend juste
qu'il ya à prendre pas non plus à
enrichir avec ses pas d'accord d'accord
mais vous avez aussi votre participation
oui bien sûr oui là c'est l'association
en fait tricot de prod qui fabrique ça
et
on a des sous de côté on a des aides on
a ça mais pour faire le plus bel objet
possible il nous faut des graphistes des
gens qui mixe le son qui et masterisé le
sont donc tout ça c'est un coup et on
s'était dit qu'on ferait comme ça de
cette manière aussi pour faire découvrir
le travail c'est une façon de les
toucher un public d'aller d'aller le
chercher puis se bouge et se dire voilà
je dis à ma famille j'en parle ma
famille j'en parle à mes amis mes amis
de mes amis de mes amis de mes amis et
au final arriver à faire connaître
davantage le projet dédié vous a aidé
qui des deux a été pour pour l'album et
pour le pour le clip si on a un clip qui
encourt 2
alors justement vendu que les ponots de
quoi ce clip donnera le clip ça va être
c'est la chanson bad pakh hard donc
c'est la chanson la plus narrative de
tout le set
et donc il parle de quoi il parle d'un
être cher qui est loi et de l'absence de
7,2 cette personne en fait voilà
d'accord ok ici le perte de l'aurès en
fait voilà elle raconte un peu sa vie au
parc vous partez quelques jours de votre
vie intime c'est bien ça si j'ai bien
compris et bien c'est ce que j'ai essayé
de vous faire comprendre tout à l'heure
en fait c'est que c'est un album concept
donc c'est une histoire qu'on raconte
d'accord excusez moi j'étais pas votre
âge effectivement on s'est mis autour
d'une table et que chacun a partagé un
peu sa vie un peu ça son ressenti son
vécu et à partir de là on a commencé à
fabriquer un personnage et puis et puis
sa vie et puis et puis des histoires
mais il ya parfois dans les chansons des
vérités alors que ça sortirait donc en
baisse c'est ça oui le 19 mai au
kabardock à lille comme l'album un album
d'un gang est sur scène ce sera quand
pour vous enfin pascal maillard vous
avez détourné aussi qu'ils sont prévus
aux enfants tous les cas envisagé disons
qu'on a joué déjà
une partie du set on joue on sort le 19
mai au kabardock et puis ensuite on est
au yo-yo ma au marché de la musique pour
essayer d'attraper des dates dehors et
dedans aussi pourquoi pas et au second
semestre on reprend avec
le principe de tournée générale d'accor
là alors je vous disais tout à l'heure
au téléphone j'avais un mot qui m'avait
complètement fait hérisser les poils de
ces termes anglais parking ne peut pas
parler français
si on peut mais ça fait bien on en
parlera françois ça fait bien fait ok je
vous propose d'écouter donc un extrait
donc de cet album donc on a retenu ses 6
806 le 6e raconte quoi parce que c'est
celui de seyssins entraîné 6,8 c'est ça
la lutte si c'est moi monsieur
ok c'est bon technicien et on écoute ça
[Musique]
là
e
on
à
[Musique]
oui c'est ça c'est la surprise de
n'avoir qu'une minute de ce morceau
alors c'est très étonnant on se demande
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'on n'entend
pas savoir c'est une surprise
c'est pas simple quand vous avez de se
voir plein de gens non non non si si
c'est l'introduction qui est longue mais
c'est l'introduction de l'album cd pour
entrer dans l'univers
voilà alors je suis pas pourquoi vous
savez que 50 secondes du russe
ces vocables d'accord non sur le disque
non sur le disque il est demandé aux
techniciens de mettre le cd le disent
que tout est bien fait mais le cd jeune
homme sait marquer
vincent services de karine
[Musique]
disons une série halo de rosalie
d'alizée
un film américain connu online
des grands loups comme des grands
joueurs la finance doit miser
l'amour passe à six rangs des coussins
sur sl poteau des cages mais la marine
bongo dont un as they et bakary que ça
donne à trouver on a donc six à huit
extraits donc de cet album est tout
s'appelle de l'ouest au 8 6 pour les
intimes 8,6 et bs6 lui ne sais pas quoi
on a peur c'est 8 906 d'elin ouais
d'accord bébé l'a trompé son synthé
justement au bas des chiffres merci où
tous les corps
culture première édition du festival de
l'océan indien expobat saint-paul du 11
au 13 mai outre les chanteurs il y aura
des artistes qui exposeront ils viennent
des trois îles de l'océan indien pour
nous en parler de thierry villendeuil de
cabaye réunion pour sa maman
mais les volets surpris eux n'ont pas su
après une saison que l'école
sinon petit nom gâté mais chiant bon
d'accord alors quinze artistes d'une
façon générale avait un truc folie douce
à lille et là dessus le papier donc le
communiqué de presse dans l'emprunt la
grande classe d'explorateurs que c'est
un festival etc
axé sur les musiques trad axé sur la
musique traditionnelle les festivals des
îles aux indiens la double ambition de
rendre hommage à la musique d'autrefois
est de faire découvrir des artistes et
des îles voisines
une édition musicale consacrée à la
musique à la musique traditionnelle
comme ladji mollahs pour l'instant mais
tient boutique autres pokémon cabaye
peut pas résoudre ça oui mais voilà mais
c'est le premier festival des îles de
l'océan indien
quand il présente en mêlant et comme on
peut dire ça c'est l'équipe de csd
production qui présente sa mort à coups
de publicités par mois des artistes
présentent la réunion aura donné le
mirage côté maurice n'aura cassia après
madagascar comprend pas tout risque la
passe contre les grandes affiches
paroisse et un bond de madagascar et non
au micro désolé les vraiment énorme donc
si oui sur scène ou bien et negro public
ici à la réunion qui suivait aussi mais
parce que c'est pas la pression due à
l'annoncé par la première fois d'accord
ok alors des artistes qui disait elle
avait dénoncé des expositions c'est quoi
ces positions des dispositions comme à
madagascar ou bien à maurice banane au
rang des exposants qui va tableau
nouveau donc le concept réunir les
sorédiens pour passer un bon jovi
plateau et passer un bon moment entre
les peuples de l'océan indien
elle était difficile de venir pour ce
premier bain depuis il fit en récupère
nom de surat déjà et ne n'est content
que nos mères ainsi mettre ça en place
dès qu'elle est valable mais d'une façon
où il a l'habitude
non non non pour les festivals aux
indiens ses premiers coups bas monde a
déjà fait des concerts mais là c'est
qu'on nous dit on peut répéter moi aussi
mais c'est vraiment le fils premier
concept du festival de sang indien et je
pense que vous avez vraiment important
optimiste ou alors tous ces bons tandis
que la dame ils pensent que c'est
agréable
alors justement on n a vu partir quelque
part la jeune et un petit peu de
l'ancienne génération à olivier briques
oui c'est une nouvelle génération pour
meichtry markov c'est un nom connaît pas
pompé ça m'agace oui ces malgaches mais
il pense que dans le milieu n'a beaucoup
de gens ici ne pense que j'en ai connu
aussi même des réunionnais qui
apprécient sa musique sa musique s'est
tue caouette c'est ça va ma partie coûté
par des gens bien l'esprit rapproché
petit peu tout ça n'est encore fait mais
c'est pas le salaire et aux danses en
deux mots les langues se marre des
actions il faut il faut il faut revoir
parce qu'ils bougent afférents bon alors
les affaires aussi nous on va voir en
parle et asseoir ses deux sites nouveau
site il sentit que me regarde comment il
y appelle à cécile oui comme travaux sur
les artistes un peu plus âgé marc sauvé
terre cuite ou non en fait si vous faire
découvrir nouvelle génération aussi que
nana ses anciens faut pas oublier aussi
qu'il peut être comme max lauret tu vas
dire - daniel roumy 0,63 toujours là et
nouvel allié il semble que oui parce que
de monier mali bien et ils apprécient
aux lycéens mais comme on l'apprendra
que sont pas tous les radicaux semblent
concerner qu'un ratisse large pratique
là je peux tout tous les goûts sur steam
à rennes festival est vraiment ouvert à
tout le monde mais tout simplement donc
comme une personne n'y pense
[Musique]
combien de vues sur la situation en
europe la situation aura tant que le
succès du rendez vous
oui mais nous l'optimisme que sinon tu
fais pas on ne sait pas ce qu'est ce qui
peut bien alors thierry villendeuil d'un
nouveau site s'appelle culture clic
réunion point re culture clic ce cas
elle hissée réunion bien sûr va mater n
y qu un nom comme une comédie aussi le
cas c'est pour nous maintenir à citer
tout simplement bien des queues de rouve
le site
nous nous sommes mis le pied à wii le
titre aux couleurs du drapeau la réunion
ok si on est le directeur de publication
et nenad de madame et accompagnants qui
va se passer ça stéphanie et sabine et
il est compliqué les difficile de
trouver des informations c'est pour ça
non mais en fait je m'étais toujours
dans la communication et la culture et
même séduit monde d'appoint donc il
continue dans ce domaine et il ne
travaille avec les différents salons de
lille et peut être 60 des grandes salles
mais pas des noms des choses que des
gens la réunion qui fait des jolies
choses pour une sculpture haut niveau tu
es à quai il faut mettre les miens sont
maintenant tout se feront au truc
différent
mon côté actionnelle sujets magazines
sur la réunion après un complément avec
eux les dates les dîners concerts d'été
atteint alors en parlant dati commence
toujours par 2018 04 25 à l'onglet un
peu quelque part effectué
les webmasters d'accord et puis le
magazine ça cette surface est facile de
constater maurice
ah non moi m'a vu mourir ou non à des
conneries
et puis la partie des priorités
d'application voilà c'est l'application
télécharger les applications
la coupe est partout ou bien voir que ça
n'a que ce qu'on verra dès ce week end
même ce soir on retrouve circuit tchèque
le crayon tout simplement aimé sauf que
la prouesse
sinon ce n'est pas vraiment bien tout
sur you des bons alors toutes les formes
de culture qui seront la toile de fond
de htpp excellent à tous de mémorables
des gouverneurs et bouillir non ben et
cléo sur des choses que peut-être que
les gens l'oublient aux cimes du rousset
n'a beaucoup de choses que les gens
oublient les nouveaux médecins la même
manière dans la lumière tout simplement
maurouard même type à la betty va
débarquer là le clic clic océans et un
concert n'aurait cependant pas les
magazines toi qui que srdjan
gouvermenent lui revient sur le serbe
était comme il précise ali tout
simplement mais ne peut parler de
l'actualité dans l'océan indien et
concerne le tourisme social et touche
qui touche tout le château n'est pas
fermée dans la culture a vraiment
que vaut ce correspondant a été
difficile de trouver nom propre nom mais
pas le meilleur mais presque ouais même
sa présente à moi ce moment d'accord
mais bien merci des contres appelle donc
les dates de concerts de 11 12 13 mai à
expobat saint-paul
le premier festival est le nom du site
culture prick craignons pas heureux
alors qu rixe avec un cas elle s'éloigne
voilà c'est ça ok merci beaucoup et on
écoute sa culture première bon eh bien
c'est marqué seule la conduite de
l'humour sur suivant
bon ben ok décidément ce soir à pas de
chance vient alors l'heure va terminer
voilà quand même
[Musique]
ne peut plus
nouvelle invention taux minimaux vie ni
batterie nimh amis nous raconte à ses
côtés ses côtés un papy les bras comme
ça
ça même que mais non
la soirée habillée de la gare
driver lajaumont indemnisation pas miser
sans thomas shaw
sally d'indécent les byzantins et nos
cadences un beau temps
rapide après tout l'inspiration sans
confrontation
comme les zones et nouba ticket nous
rentrer comme étalonner
balance les coups bas
[Musique]
des de l'arrosoir côté là
sega
commettre la même
[Musique]
soit
baby déclare vouloir côté
yang et de dragueur rabat témara
benzaghou ye yang yang est devenue la
gare
souvent qu'un bug qui fait raconté
combatif rcga sympathie mais des
certificats même qui 2 hannibal
tabourier à beyrouth
at on annoncé
madame combat passe sous la voiture de
ali mendiola mme benita mini bac dit
mamie nos rosa comme ça
chico des six côtés un thé apathie 14,3
douleur
on a bataillé
non quand ça comme ça
comment raisonner nouba ticket nous
rentrer
thomson la maisonnée ramadan coupât ici
[Musique]
avec la beaujoire
côté dégâts
matt et marama à couillet
nous avions
m
[Musique]
les gones kouba easy bake l'arrosoir
côté dames
marama ça y est
yang et deux au lagon
dom est là mais dans l'est
balance tout ego ou pas ici elle découpe
annaba nommé dans la zone habitée klaus
voire koné nano s'égare
[Musique]
la gare
et
aubin invités du premier festival de
l'océan indien en mai bonsoir cécile
lavayssière dans ça on termine par vous
vous êtes la présidente de la lanterne
magique l'association fête ses 20 ans 20
ans à imaginer rêver réalisées chaque
année cinémarmailles le festival de
cinéma jeune public du nord de la
réunion
cette année la lanterne magique a
souhaité donner un cas particulier cette
édition c'est quoi cet éclat particulier
alors juste une petite précision c'est
le festival cinéma et qui fête ses 20
ans et n'ont pas la lanterne magique
lanterne magique elle est née en 2002 et
cinémarmailles c'est un festival jeune
public de cinéma qui était d'abord porté
par la ville de saint denis et qui a
ensuite été confiée à la lanterne
magique avant defla portique eu lieu
l'éclat particulier parce qu'on n'a pas
tous les jours 20 ans et que on s'était
dit que cette année on avait envie de
donner une dimension particulière au
festival une dimension festive joyeuse
y a pas de thématique dans la
programmation il ya juste l'envi que ça
pétille ça pétille un peu plus à leur
portée
pardonnez moi mon impertinence mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a pas plus de
programmation habitudes en termes de
films n'ont par contre on a deux invités
qu'on a fait venir d'hexagone on est
très très contents
ce sont des gens qui sont spécialisés
dans la musique de film et qui font des
ciné concerts sont des grands jazzmen
donner leurs bombes
oui alors leurs maraudes et nicolas
thomas donc un inquiet italien
et l'autre qui est français ils sont
dans l'expérimentation musicale laurent
marode ilan honnête par exemple et puis
nicolas tomasi les vibrations bribois ce
nombre a sonné voilà donc ça c'est c'est
quand même un instrument qui est pas
très très connu duke ellington
par exemple en termes de jazz je suis
plus à l'aise en cinéma que j'aime
beaucoup le jazz mais parlons cinéma je
ferai plus à l'aise et donc ils ont la
particularité aussi de proposer un
atelier musique de film qui met en
lumière un aspect du cinéma qu'on
connaît peu finalement qu'est la
création de musiques de films alors ça
s'adresse à un public de quel âge
ça s'adresse à un public qui va de 3 ans
jusqu'à jusqu'à un public adulte
puisqu'on a des projections tout public
alors je parle de cet atelier musical
atelier 7 à 77 ans c'est vraiment un
atelier qui peut réunir tous les âges
d'ailleurs il s'adapte en fonction de
l'âge et cette année particularité
nouveauté aussi on en partenariat avec
la ffr l'agent ce film réunion pour en
avant première du festival
un après midi ciné concerts et ateliers
musique de film qui est ouvert à tout le
monde et qui est aussi en particulier
dédié aux élèves qui bénéficient
des actions d'éducation aux images menée
par la ffr parce que c'est la terre qui
pilote les dispositifs d'éducation
cinéma et vous souffle de l'onu que son
image nous on fait de l'éducation aux
images andy aux images parce que l'image
elle est multiple maintenant les écrans
sont multiples l'image est multiple avec
cyrielle ja chez oui et puis à dean
scholtès aussi on a deux salariés qui
sont dédiées à l'éducation aux images
c'est un travail qui est très très
important pour la lanterne magique et
c'est un travail de fond qui est peu
spectaculaire qui peu visible et en même
temps quand on est dans le festival
cinéma mailloux dans nos actions de
diffusion on fait aussi de l'éducation
image alors l'ouverture gratuite à
l'hôtel de ville de saint-denis
ça va ya voir exactement jours
d'ouverture alors le jour de l'ouverture
le ciné concert évidemment on met en
lumière nos invités ciné concert autour
du film minuscule qui a un film très
malicieux très rigolo qui utilise deux
techniques prises de vues réelles et
puis animations donc ça c'est gratuit
c'est à partir de 18h et c'est le 4 mai
à l'hôtel de ville et on remercie la
ville de saint denis de mettre à
disposition ce lieu comme chaque année
pour signer les luges l'illustration
musicale et ont directement
oui c'est ça le principe du ciné concert
c'est que le la musique se fait chanter
crée ton chez charlot comme tous les
premiers films en fait où les films
cinéma muet se faisait était projeté au
cinéma et l'orchestré se trouvait devant
et le bonimenteur aussi se trouver
devant le public bien alors donc ça
c'est vendredi samedi vous pèse présenté
entre autres au millennium
oui alors ça c'est aussi ce qu'on a à
coeur de faire cesser de s'ouvrir à la
production et à la création locale
zombillénium il est issu des studios
pipangaï à la réunion et ont fait venir
quelqu'un du studio pipangaï pour
présenter le film est entré un peu dans
les coulisses de la fabrication du film
on a la chance d'avoir ce très grand
studio d'animation ici à damas a été
fait à la réunion enbil hennium a été
fait à la réunion et le dernier ses
crocs blancs aussi donc c'est un studio
qui reconnu dans le monde entier
donc voilà on essaie de faire du lien
avec ce qui se fait ici et puis de faire
venir des gens qui ont contribué à la
fabrication du film et venir présenter
leur travail
alors ça se passe aussi sur le square
labourdonnais
voilà donc cette année ce sont les 20
ans de cinéma remail on garde la formule
cinéma en salle au ciné la case et on
voulait donner un éclat particulier au
village marmaille puisque on ne peut pas
imaginer un festival sans qu'ils aient
un espace récréatif convivial qui
permettent aux familles de venir se
reposer aux enfants de venir participer
à des ateliers et donc on a une
proposition d'atelier très importante au
village marmaille à partir du samedi
après midi sont des ateliers qui sont
gratuits pour la plupart certains sont
payants et ses 5 euros/mois là est
d'ailleurs concernant les tarifs des
séances on a une double tarification à 3
euros pour les enfants et les adhérents
de la lanterne magique et 5 euros comme
tarif normal de fraîcheur par donc le
tricheur c'est très cher je courais non
on essaie quand même de nom c'est pas
très cher on fait vraiment un effort
sachant qu'on est quand même une
association et que on a besoin d'eux
d'avoir quelques recettes propres alors
vous donc l éducation aux images pour
des enfants je suppose que ces
personnes-là participe aussi donc aux
prix enfin au concours le prix cinéma
oui donc que le prix cinéma maïs à un
prix qu'on a mis en place il ya quelques
années et qui consiste à faire une
sélection de films que l'on reçoit quand
on visionne auparavant et david locaux
oui c'est ça son choix des films
d'amateurs donc réalisé par des jeunes
de 6 à 18 ans soit des films d'amateurs
soit des films d'ateliers comme ce qu'on
peut faire à la lanterne magique à des
associations qui font des interventions
scolaires ou dans les bibliothèques qui
font des petits films donc là aussi
c'est mettre en avant tout ce travail
d'éducation images tout ce travail sur
le terrain et de le projeter sur un
grand écran et le confronter au regard
aussi des professionnels de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma locaux donc
cette année
voilà armand dauphin jean marc la case
et elsa dahmani elle a été déjà
aux jurés du prix cinémarmailles l'année
dernière c'est la fondatrice et la
présidente la directrice de signer cours
l oeuvre beaucoup aussi pour la
production locale à la réunion en
particulier de courts métrages
jean-marc la casse est un ami de longue
date de la lanterne magique c'est un
artiste complet jean-marc il est
plasticien il est vidéaste donc on a
toujours grand bonheur à travailler avec
lui et armand dauphin qu'on connaît
depuis très longtemps qu'on croise et
qu'on avait envie aussi d'intégrer à
l'aventuré chez man 2 sur wii c'est ça
ouais ouanna qui qui projette des films
au ritz qui a une grille a réussi
seulement que je voulais vous demander
ma question
ah oui un atelier musique bruitages oui
ça ça attire des jeunes ça bien sûr on
aura pas comment on fait des pas de
chevaux le feu et cetera des choses
comme ça le préfet aurait été dû du
technicien me dit il le bruitage c'est
ce qui permet un film d'animation
d'exister par exemple un film
d'animation c'est juste des images
comment le fait exister comme en donne
du relief aux images comment on et off
ce que montre l'image c'est parle comme
on fait du vent qu'on fait la mer avec
des choses qui peuvent être très très
simple payant mais les démos de coco
pour faire les sabots des shows cc des
choses très simples et justes aussi pour
dire 20 ans 20 ans de
de cinémarmailles cette année et un
partenariat nouveau aussi puisque
cinémarmailles va se délocaliser à
saint-benoît alors je sors je n'en parle
au bambou avec les bambous à cinéma
cristal le 9 mai avec deux films jeune
public c'est vraiment le le jeune public
et le très jeune public
c'est un public qui nous tient à coeur
que l'on a envie de toucher le très
jeune public il a trois ans pour la
première fois qu'il va au cinéma
donc on a une attention particulière à
la programmation de ces solutions vous
présenter quoi des séquences très dure
de trois minutes
non non c'est en général c'est une série
de deux films qui n'excède pas 40
minutes
vous arrivez à faire en sorte qu'ils
restent dans le la salle 500 go sont
bougés finissants des courts métrages
donc ça donne la liberté aux parents de
savoir si jamais il ya un soucis peuvent
sortir entre deux bons mètres âge en
général les enfants sont très preneur on
a de très beaux films tchèques la
l'animation de chèques par exemple fait
des choses très très belle et on a des
enfants qui sont qui reste captivé par
ces images il ya beaucoup de poésie ya
beaucoup de choses sensibles c'est ça
qu'on a envie de leur montrer aux
enfants pourquoi vous dévoilerons
bientôt signer la case aussi dans mon
copain le cristal le signe de la case
saint denis pourquoi pas voir et
exceptionnellement puisque vous fêtez
vos vingt ans pour 2 cinémarmailles
l'ouest ou le sud parce que notre
principal financeur c'est la ville de
saint denis est donc maintenant tu as
faim denis bien les enfants ils peuvent
participer à des ateliers lorsqu'ils ont
trois ans et on arrive aussi à le
captiver non trois ans un peu difficile
parce qu'il faut une certaine habileté
manuelle donc les ateliers ce à partir
de 5 8 ans et ça se termine quand donc
ce dimanche
dimanche 6 mai avec une projection la
soirée de clôture déjà et puis une
projection en plein air au square
labourdonnais deux projections plus en
plus secondes de projections en plein
air gratuite
edward aux mains d'argent le samedi soir
et shaun le mouton et soirée de clôture
le dimanche
merci cinéma